en ce moment les informations autour du
cou vite 19 sont loin d'être légère mais
voilà une belle histoire comme on
aimerait en lire plus souvent qui donne
espoir et qui nous prouve que rien est
écrit d'avancé
anna del vals est une heureuse grand
mère espagnole de 107 ans il ya quelques
semaines malgré les précautions qu'elle
a prises
elle est atteinte par le coronavirus
résidents d'un établissement pour
personnes âgées elle est rapidement
prise en charge par le personnel
soignant qui n'est pas très optimiste
pourtant très vite son état s'améliore
en quelques jours seulement elle
retrouve l'appétit et recommencent même
à utiliser son déambulateur
mais la folle histoire ne s'arrête pas
là car anna del valle né en 1913 juste
après la première guerre mondiale en
1918 alors qu'elle n'a que 5 ans et les
victimes de la grippe espagnole qui
ravage le monde entier et fera des
millions de victimes
là encore elle réussit à se guérir en
quelques jours et reprend rapidement du
poil de la bête en un siècle et cette
dame aura traversé deux des pires
catastrophes sanitaires contemporaine à
chaque fois elle aura été atteinte et à
chaque fois elle sera remise
une histoire à peine croyable qui
redonne de l'espoir
ouais c'est beau passer franchement anna
del vals
non mais franchement anna del valle elle
a traversé les deux plus grosses crises
sanitaires et elle est encore là ça me
rappelle franchement il ya deux
personnes qui ont fait ça garranah
delval et isabelle morini bosc qui sera
je pense que tu fais un trottoir glacé à
la et à lisa belouin haut niveau ce
qu'elle a traversé l a terrassé toutes
églises et à traverser la crise de 29
elle a traversé il ya eu là la crise de
la dîme au moyen-âge
la clis de l'animalité la région jura
était la voix ce qui a été comme ça et
take les petits spots voilà il amène
money boss lui redire et isabelle morini
bosc à côtés d'isabelle morini-bosc rené
mal dit séka madame st isabelle jeu la
danse mois puis tu seras continue dans
l'émission vous dire que ça promet alors
la valeur ava tamba d'ailleurs à la 2e
de la salle ça va être génial
alors c'est une belle histoire qui donne
de l'espoir là je voudrais donner à
quelques nerfs parole à quelqu'un qui a
toujours le sourire quoi qu'il arrive là
faudel du paf
valérie kumm présente comme ça je suis
tout à fait d'accord il faut avoir le
sourire et se penser en ces temps un
petit peu difficile
et là c'est par la très très jolie
histoire parce qu'on imaginait tête
évidemment que ses jours étaient comptés
à cette pauvre dame
et là franchement miracle on peut parler
de miracle et ça fait du baume au coeur
parce qu'on a comme les histoires
difficiles on voit que les histoires de
réanimation qui éventuellement tourne
mal et là pour le coup on a une jolie
histoire moi je suis preneur
je prends toutes les délinquances